there's a reason why we got that freedom
convoy yeah yeah yeah
so are you all supporting the racist
homophobic misogynistic
i want to support the people that want
to kill me for sure i'm just waiting for
a truck to come by so i'm like hey take
me home daddy yeah
yeah if i get to do another comedy show
run me over bro
i'm so mad i sat by the road somebody's
trying to give me cookies i'm like i
thought i thought the kkk was about to
roll through she had cookies they were
baking stuff blankets little gingerbread
man
come on you want some poutine they got
that [ __ ] by the side of the road it's
crazy oh what's happening montreal too
yes
right it's happening in my hometown of
ottawa shitty place but it's the case i
don't know you're from ottawa i was born
there but i grew up elsewhere okay
gotcha all right so break it down for
like us americans and like there's other
foreigners that are watching this
podcast because we're just getting the
american version of it right and
obviously that's very skewed right
because the left is going to be like oh
yeah these racist people have organized
this protest they're terrorizing the
city they're occupying it and then the
right is basically going no these are
peaceful people and the is coming
together and look they cleaned down the
the statue of the one leg guy that used
to run in canada right like
whatever the guy's name is i don't know
terry fox yeah
okay
so so what is it what's going on and
like where do canadians stand on it
when it started out it started out as
just
to enter back in canada truckers would
have to
uh do 14 days of quarantining if they
don't get vaccinated after they've left
the u.s they went they went to the u.s
and they want to come back in canada
right they would say yo you're gonna
have to
you're gonna have to do 14 days of
quarantine unless you get vaccinated and
you got to get vaccinated the thing is
90 of the truckers are vaccinated they
already are yeah they are it's just that
they said
even for that time but they went they
just tilted they went like you know what
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
give the [ __ ] it's not so much that all
the the the the the truckers are not
that they are most of them are
principal it's just like when that you
know what [ __ ] it yeah [ __ ] it and then
they march
it started with that
and then they just added a whole bunch
of things okay now we have demanded so
remove all the minutes we know it it
it doesn't work like that it doesn't
work remove all those magnets and stuff
like that so now it's bigger it's bigger
than
anti-vax people and you feel like canada
is supporting this
you feel like most canadians are rocking
with them and
interesting
i think people see the support online
and assume that but actually most
canadians so can is very different from
the states most canadians support the
mandates the vaccine mandates all that
stuff locked down by polls by all the
numbers even though the support has
dwindled over time it's still a majority
so they're supporting the lockdowns and
all the measures i know because i live
in quebec and even though a lot of the
young people in montreal are not down
with it the rest of the province doesn't
give a [ __ ] really they're fine with a
lot of this if you're not maybe if
you're not even the restaurants even no
they like obviously the business owners
are really hurt by it so they can't
stand it yeah but if you're talking
about the people who matter who are the
voters to the politicians right then the
voters they're with it and the voters
the voters are boomers yeah that's
interesting the voters don't care about
the restaurant tour they don't give a
[ __ ]
i don't care
don't care about clubs comedy clubs they
don't care about restaurants
industries they don't do that i actually
saw this was the i was in an uber and
there was a guy i had the radio on and
he was talking to this old guy who lives
out and been in the boonies and he's
like how do you feel about the fact that
a lot of young people they're depressed
some of them are feeling suicidal they
feel like their social lives you know
they can't see their friends from high
school or they can't hang out with
anybody like they're really being hurt
by all the restrictions don't you have
any sympathy for them he's like oh [ __ ]
him [ __ ] the clubs [ __ ] it everybody
tell them to stay home it's none of my
[ __ ] there's zero consideration for the
younger generation
and so that sentiment is very pervasive
they don't care and everyone's kind of
out there for their own self-interest in
that regards i we're getting none of
that here no the only version of that
and maybe you guys are seeing different
[ __ ] than me but the only version of
that i get is from trudeau yeah and from
the politicians yeah where they're
hiding right now yo that was nowhere to
[ __ ] [ __ ] right that's him
why y'all vote for this guy man we
bring you back canadians
hey
hey don't put everybody in the same pot
you know what it is it's not that enough
y'all
he didn't win
the field lost
that's [ __ ] even right there yeah
how you got a loser in as president like
they're good with the status quo yeah
yeah they're good with this and he also
timed his election really intelligently
that's the most canadian [ __ ] ever you
only have to win win it probably
wait a minute you were like the loser
you elected the loser brother don't the
white guy got a minority movement don't
you [ __ ] do that too all right
fine technically trump did win because
they still
yeah
okay hold on recount it
well listen we tried to make a change
some of us went down there yeah
dude we had our own little freedom
convoy
he
[Laughter]
that was mad but yeah no um canadians
overwhelmingly support
um the mandates but you're seeing a lot
of people online who are behind it
people from other countries so online if
you're consuming it that way you get the
vibe yeah that you know what was
interesting you know what was crazy you
know that their gofundme was yeah it was
criticism but you know who did it they
actually admitted it who it was the
mayor of ottawa him and the government
was the governor for me and they said we
want this shutdown and gofundme accepted
he came on interviewing yeah what yeah
so the government got with a private
institution it was good and now gofundme
is not going to return the money they're
going to give it to other random chiefs
no that's not true you can get your
money back you can they don't want to
give the money back okay because they
get three percent right right so they
don't want to give back that three
percent obviously but if you ask for
your money you can't get it back if you
don't ask for it they're gonna just
disagree naturally that's what they do
that's crazy to me but here's that's
what they do in these situations i was
looking that up like if you give money
to a charity then they can't you know
they can't give it to someone they don't
automatically give it back to you
because they wanted that little
that little piece yeah yeah but if you
guys are good the government can step in
if i could go and manipulate a private
business i wouldn't say myself the last
time i checked it was like
45
agree with the convoy so it's not
overwhelming but it's still the majority
still agrees against it yeah i mean so
but
i don't know it's um we'll see we'll see
what's going on
yeah
with the whole cancellation of the golf
on me with them moving to another city
like they were really in ottawa now
they're really in uh quebec city no is
it true that they're calling it an
occupation now and that's why
the gofundme was going to take it
because a gofundme can support it was
smearing a protest it's all smeared
right it's all smear it's also how do
you guys feel is like like canada is
supposed to be this like progressive
loving like everybody gets along country
and it has these a lot of amazing things
like i think one thing i admire about
canada is it seems to and again this is
from the outside it seems like canada
does a good job of getting
most people on board with the canadian
sentiment right it seems like there
isn't there is a love of being canadian
and then that can cross cultural
barriers too like there is this idea of
like hey we gotta look out for one
another and that's the right thing to do
and we can be proud of that it's just
that our pr is better than yours um
[Music]
your political opposition isn't as
extreme
like even your right wing doesn't even
touch our left yet
yet
i could get there i do think that
there's far more trust in our
institutions than you guys have in yours
okay that's because our institutions
don't have the same rep that your yours
do wow they haven't broken your trust
just yet no and if you think about
quality of life i'm pretty sure if you
look at the happiness index we're to
rank higher than you guys okay why
because a lot of our basic needs are
taken care of for the most part we have
good social safety nets we got health
care for people you know i mean we don't
have the same issues in terms of like if
you're poor there's a lot more
opportunity for you in canada to be here
in the states right so i think in terms
of the general sentiment towards the
government we're mo far ahead of you
guys in that regards right and so
when the government says we're going to
do a lockdown well they've earned a lot
more trust from us like you guys must be
right
where we've had the government [ __ ] us
over for like i don't trust these
[ __ ]
who's really behind this exactly big
pharma want to lock it down like who's
really profiting off of this so you guys
believe but now you have these instances
where you see the government yeah using
their power
to kind of silence individual citizens
do you start to lose a little bit of
faith for your government it's called a
brittle a bit but it's not it's not the
same it's going to take a lot more and
that's why i said yet we're not there
yet but i mean if they keep on going
like that it's going to happen it's just
that their their pr is better than yours
yeah you america's been known to say
[ __ ] you
a lot more than [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] you
nah [ __ ] them
that's you guys but that's culturally
that's who we are like and the people i
understand but the people who come here
they're the [ __ ] you people yeah like
everybody who comes to america one
person in their family looked at the
country they were from and all their
family members were like i don't need
y'all
i don't know if you can attest to this i
feel like immigrants even in canada like
people from minority backgrounds already
have before this pandemic not [ __ ]
with the government yeah those are
coming from places where the government
is corrupt
the government of canada doesn't have
the greatest representation you know
reputation with the indigenous people
for example what
wait what happened
what happened
did something happen the native american
he's an expert on that he got a machete
from them so he knows all about him
it's called a tomahawk yeah yeah
that's real
that's real that's real
but yeah they think let's not act like
they didn't find the bodies of uh six
thousand kids whoa in uh yeah in the
residence halls just don't don't don't
let's not act like jimmy carter
let's not act like we all breezy with
the native let's let's not act like
uh natives don't have uh clean drinking
water in the restoration let's let's
yeah come on now yeah oh yeah we're all
good
yeah so i i think i think it's harder
for us to gauge that level of trust
because i've always kind of had that to
some degree so i don't know how the more
white populous would feel about how
things are shifting i don't know
i'm kind of isolated from that we kind
of see some [ __ ] up [ __ ] sometimes
just like
you hang around the natives you're like
okay yeah you you you've been [ __ ]
over just just like what they didn't
okay cool same thing
how do the natives feel about the convoy
oh they're some of them are with them
that's interesting yeah yeah because
some of the people from the convoy are
actually requested some of them
requested yo can we do something about
the water yeah can you do something
about the water it's been time and
trudeau said that he would do something
about the water six years ago and he
received i believe was 1.8 billion
dollars in funding wow
what do you think he did with that
bought paint oh black paper
face right isn't that allowed yeah
yeah i feel like that's different no it
is different i feel like it is different
isn't it not because i do yellow face
isn't that different no i don't think
it's different i think it's different
because there's no cultural like um
example
of like with blackface there's examples
of black people not being allowed to
succeed in certain institutions and it's
a mockery of black people in film right
if we've seen that with brown face
then i would go
okay maybe we can't do that if there's
no history of that then you should be
able to do brownface yeah so it's not
like it's offensive to put the color on
your face it's offensive to remind us of
this time period where black people were
mocked and cinnamon
i would just ask brown people i'll just
ask how y'all
[Laughter]
what cool story did come out though what
uh they were trying to get tow trucks to
tow away
the the the the freedom convoy and
they're like nah we're not doing that
yeah we're not we're not though
no we're not helping you guys you got to
find someone else
because they work so close to that let's
see
right there bro yeah we're not doing it
it's like you defending rogan like
you're not going to do nothing that's my
god that's where the instructors get
their trainings
but they're like i'm going to tow
these [ __ ] are going to hire me
yeah
i ain't [ __ ] up my job hell no
i'm on the news and now they know aren't
you that guy on the news that throw the
truck uh [ __ ]
i just love seeing canadians angry that
[ __ ] is the
best it still is still so we're not
going to [ __ ] stand for it anymore
like
you know that came straight away
when black people do like the white guy
voice in comedy
that's how i feel doing canadians voices
okay
when i hear canadians i think that's
what black people hear when they hear
white people you feel employable yet
what
are you saying i'm not employable
that's the manager's standing yeah oh my
god i'm separated
you